you how you are charging our phones
there is no electricity again but this
time poor Mata only has a backup plan a
solar charging unit that makes with the
light stay on and some plugs in her
house work
my mother she's diabetic
so she's using
the injections to to minimize it so I
had to put it in the fridge
so if the power is off it's useless
because it has to stay in a cold weather
I mean a cold place
when Paul uses a pay as you go
Innovation that's providing off-grid
solar power to low-income households
people pay an initial deposit of about
30 the balance less than sixty dollars
is paid off in installments
it's giving South Africans access to
technology they wouldn't usually be able
to afford frequent payments that will
ensure that you have a profile that will
say okay you you are a payer and you you
actually follow through with your
payments with that being said over a
number of time you will you will get to
your deposit amount and then when the
deposit amount is reached you will be
able to receive the unit
the state-owned power company escom is
struggling to meet demand aging and
poorly maintained infrastructure is
partly to blame but these kind of
solutions of Off the Grid is the only
way to go currently as we are aware that
our infrastructure Solutions currently
in terms of what we have in South Africa
would not be able to hand it handle
hybrid Solutions like being undergrad
and off the grid
planned outages have been implemented
Countrywide known as load shedding it's
when the state power company switches
off electricity at certain times of the
day to take pressure off the National
Grid South Africa used to generate
Surplus electricity even selling to
neighboring countries now people are
being told to use power sparingly until
a long term a viable solution is found
energy sector and let's say generating
sufficient supplies of electricity for
all South Africans will take time
possibly years
getting as many households as possible
connected to Alternative and affordable
energy sources could be a better and
faster solution
Al Jazeera Johannesburg